[Musique]
je demain
je lui dis que je ne l'aime plus
J'avoue qu'à sa place tu es là maintenant
toi
contre l'étrange attraction des deux
mains
je faisais
avec le sentiment que je l'attends
[Musique]
si avec moi je vais devoir
les diviser
[Musique]
mieux respirer lentement
bonheur
[Musique]
tu ne sais pas de quoi je ne serais pas capable
je
Demain
je lui dis que je ne lis pas
[Musique]
comme la neige fondue ou le sentiment
être seul
peut-être un peu à la fois on se dira juste
un mot
Regarde-moi au fil des ans
[Musique]
si quelqu'un meurt
tu ne sais pas de quoi je ne serais pas capable
Je demain semble solitaire mais je recommence
tu es mort Tu es dès le premier instant le
portable
moi demain Qu'est-ce que tu dis?
[Applaudissements]
mon histoire d'amour était vraiment
heureux
[Musique]